morning at eight eastern
48 hours of non-fiction books all
weekend every weekend
on book tv
next an encore presentation of our book
notes program seen every sunday night on
our companion network c-span
in october of last year historian alfred
young appeared to discuss his book the
shoemaker and the tea party it's the
story of george robert twelves a poor
shoemaker an active participant in some
of the key events in the american
revolution
it's about an hour
alfred f young
author of the shoemaker and the tea
party what is your book all about
my book is about
an ordinary man
who lived in boston a good part of his
life
and was a shoemaker all of his life
and who was active in most of the famous
events of the american revolution that
took place in boston
the boston massacre the washington tea
party the touring and feathering of
people
then he became a soldier and sailor in
the revolution
and uh
left boston
lived out his life in country towns and
then when he was in his 90s he was quote
discovered in western new york someone
wrote a biography of him and he was
brought back to boston
in 1835 when someone wrote another
biography of him
he was the hero of the day for the 4th
of july
his portrait was painted
and he became a celebrity
and his name is george robert 12
he apparently was asked that and uh he
said it was he thought he was named
after
um an ancestor on his mother's side
uh but he didn't know any more than that
i've since learned it's a welsh name and
that made sense because his uh
his father was uh
his
the whole family was descended from the
first settlers who came here uh from
wales you brought this picture along
with you and it's actually a picture of
a portrait it's in the book what is it
uh when he came back to boston in 1935
the family commissioned a portrait and
this is it
uh
so the portrait portrays him
not as a shoemaker but in his sunday
best clothes
an old man leaning on a cane
and the picture was called the
centenarian because hughes thought he
was 99 years old let's be on the verge
of a hundred
he was wrong he was off by six years he
was only 93. he wasn't i don't think it
was an intentional lying
but um
he then passes into history as a a near
hundred-year-old man and as the last
survivor of the tea party he wasn't the
last survivor there were 25 others but
that was a kind of sign of they didn't
know all the people who had been in the
tea party you said just as we sat down
that you've been working on this book
for 20 years
well the original essay uh appeared in
the william mary quarterly some years
ago in 1981.
i'd been working on it for several years
before then
and the essay has had a second life
because uh
oh it was voted best essay in the year
and the best essay in five years and
then in 1993 uh the the william mary
quarterly is the leading journal in
early american history
it was voted one of the 10 most
influential articles in 50 years of that
magazine so
it then had a second life and i received
an offer from beacon press to publish it
and bring it to a broader audience so
the book consists of that essay plus a
new essay with my second thoughts about
this man
my 20 years later why do you care about
this man
well i've i've long been very unhappy
with the uh traditional interpretation
of ordinary people in the revolution if
i didn't start out to do this man's
biography
i started out with questions about what
was the role of ordinary people in
making the revolution in boston
what were their ideas
uh did they have an impact on events
and were they changed in the course of
that so i was looking for for someone to
peg this on because it's very hard to do
this kind of history and
these people leave people at that level
of society they're called mechanics in
those days
they don't write large numbers of
letters they don't keep diaries
uh
not like the famous people the
jeffersons and the atoms for whom we
the the papers run to 50 volumes and
we're still not done with them
but uh in the course of doing research
on boston i came across these two
biographies one eighteen thirty four one
eighteen thirty five we would call them
as told to biographies
and they both were of the same man and i
thought that was quite extraordinary
and then at another point i realized
that this portrait which was hanging in
the old state house the top of a spiral
staircase was a portrait of the same man
it was called the centenarian and i had
to piece it together that oh there may
be
the guy whose life i could trace
and
um do a life of an ordinary person in
the revolution
so
that's how i landed on him
you have some uh
population figures i just want to throw
out right in boston in 1770 15 000
people in 1810 34 000 people in 1820 43
000 people and in 1830 61 000 people
where did the revolution start
well i don't think you can say the
revolution starts in boston but boston
is one of the key cities uh and boston
play has an influence
boston was considered the capital of new
england the leading seaport
it's the major city in
massachusetts and
boston the the leadership of the patriot
movement give in boston not only leads
boston but leads the colony it leads the
new england region and is very
influential and it's no um
we're not wrong in in naming in
identifying some of the famous events
the boston massacre the boston tea party
and they seem to they play an enormous
role in shaping of public policy
so i don't think we any longer there
used to be a long fight of who was who
was more important in virginia or new
york i don't think the historians uh uh
like to get bogged down in that sort of
thing anymore but this
the reason i chose boston was because
boston was very difficult to understand
and uh
it was very important so if i had an
ordinary man who seemed to be a man in
the streets of boston i had a man one of
the most important cities when did you
start
talking about this man what year in
their book in the book
he's born in 1742
in boston
he's the son of a tanner
who had fallen on a poor ways
uh
george his father dies when he's about
five or six years old he's raised by his
mother so i was able through these two
biographies to follow him through
childhood then he becomes an apprentice
apprentice to a shoemaker it was very
hard to get an apprenticeship you know
what would be called a higher trade
apprenticeship
uh is a means of we would call
vocational education that's the main
education for most boys
in those days
and
i follow him through his apprenticeship
then he opens a little shop on his own
on griffin's wharf or near griffin's
wharf which is the place where the tea
party took place
and uh then he be then i was then i was
able to pick him up as he becomes
involved in political activity
in the late 1760s
when
you
you know you talk about three different
things a lot of things you talk about
but the massacre
the feathering of john malcolm and the
tea party this what happened first
the massacre well the first the first
big activity in boston is around the
stamp act which is 1765 1766
uh and that's where an awful lot of
working people are involved the uh
the leader of the popular demonstrations
is a shoemaker whose name was ebenezer
mcintosh
uh he had formally been leader of the
annual november 5th guy fawkes day
ritual which is in america called pope's
day
and he was chosen by the political
leaders
to help organize the demonstrations
against the stan against the stamp back
what was the stamp act start with that
the stamp act is an act of parliament um
taxing
putting the tax on printed matter
newspapers books pamphlets even playing
cards and attacks on legal documents
deeds
and it arouses a storm in the colonies
so it passed by the british parliament
and overrides the american legislators
in boston or in massachusetts it would
be typical of the other colonies
there are town meetings each year the
town meeting sent a delegate to a
central government called the general
court popularly known as the assembly
and the assembly passes laws for the
colony and there's a royal governor
who's appointed by the king and a
council appointed by the king through
the royal governor which is a kind of a
cabinet or upper house
the
uh
laws of parliament take precedence over
the laws of the uh colonial assembly and
your main character uh
george robert twelves hughes was a
british citizen then
all americans would would be britishers
and they would think of themselves as
britishers at some point they i think
they've already started to think of
themselves as british americans and i
think at some point in the revolution
they think of themselves as americans so
in 1770 the massacre occurs what is it
well
the uh there are also laws on uh
uh governing trade trade regulations and
these laws are violated the british
repealed the stamp act because of the
protest but they insist on the principle
that they have the right to pass laws
regulating trade or in all cases
whatsoever including new taxes
they pass new uh trade regulations and
new tax laws
there's more
uh
of a much more violent sort then they
send troops to boston to enforce the
laws so they send some four thousand
troops to a city of fifteen thousand
which means they're very much of a
presence
and as far as i could figure out use it
not been active on the stamp act
demonstrations it could have been but he
doesn't speak of them in in these as
told to biographies but he starts
talking about the revolution at the
point where the soldiers arrive in town
and then he reacts
very much to the personal things that
take place on the street so he sees he
sees a soldier
hit a woman and rob her or he
himself um
men's shoes for some a shoemaker would
then be called a corduena or a cobbler a
corduena made shoes and a complimented
shoes he did both he men shoes for a
british captain
and he's not paid he protests
and the soldier involved not the captain
of the soldier is a whipped is as a
punishment and used as a paul that he
caused this man to be whipped
uh so there's a series of personal
things which arouse arouse him
against soldiers
and then there's a event which is since
famous soldiers uh moonlighted that they
were allowed to take off-duty jobs so
one evening uh the
front the massacre is a monday night
on the friday before the soldier asks
for work at a rope walk
and the
rope walk workers tell him where he can
go with a great deal of profanity more
soldiers come in there's a fight between
the rope walk workers and the soldiers
both sides are furious the soldiers are
beaten the soldiers vow for revenge that
they're going to get even with the
town's people townspeople avow they're
not going to take any more of this sort
of stuff and that's the matrix of the
event which leads to the killing on
march 5th which is then called the
boston massacre what happens who's
killed
uh
hughes tells the story
that the this all be it begins in the
night of the fifth with
an apprentice
an apprentice boy
yelling at one of the soldiers
that the soldier did not pay
his master who was a barber for some
work in the barber shop and there's a
fight over this or there's a an exchange
there's a gathering of people
there's
there are uh not a large crowd at first
but
the
the people in the crowd are angry with
the soldiers for
hurting the apprentice boy this is the
way hughes tells the story
and then there's then the the
people
start throwing snowballs and the
snowballs probably are laced with stones
at that point
the god is called out some six or seven
soldiers and they form a circle to
protect the century who was standing
there
and
soon there's a larger gathering of
townspeople so there may be a hundred or
so people in the square
the town's people taunt the soldiers to
fire fire fire dare you we're standing
in the king's highway we have a we have
a right to stand here the soldiers are
restrained
at some point there's a shouting of fire
and the soldiers fire
and they shoot into the crowd
and four people are killed
and several others are wounded what year
is this again this is 1770 march 5th
1770.
uh uses present
he was not armed but he came out as he
said
because he knew his town's people were
under attack and as he remembered it
years later remember he's remembering
these stories
60 years later as they're being set down
we can talk about his memory
um
one of the men james caldwell falls in
his arms wounded
and hughes remembers 60 years later that
he took him to dr thomas young on such
and such a lane and then he went to
another lane to inform
uh caldwell's ship captain that he had
been shot
he's what 28 then
it would be 42.
he would be a young man and in 1970 what
was the atmosphere around the colony
1770
they were i think there was a kind of
low
there'd been a lot of protests all over
the colonies on the stamp act
uh and the stamp act was withdrawn then
the trade regulations are enforced then
there are more taxes it's a kind of lull
before the storm the
coming of the soldiers only is in is in
the colony of massachusetts
and does not arouse the rest of the
colonies as much although they're
watching this
the massacre
as it's called by the patriots then
arouses large numbers of people all over
who are frightened of this you mean at
that time in 70 there were no other
british troops in the country no there
are other british troops there are
british troops in the cities and there
are british troops on the frontier uh
but not on a scale of boston and there's
no
there are presence so in new york there
had long been fights between troops and
uh
working people are these troops all
brits they are actually from britain uh
some of them are well british isles so
some would be irish
some might be scotch irish but they're
not american they're not americans not
at all no
then
the tea party what year does that come
tea party is uh three years later 1773.
you call it it's not what didn't call it
no they called it the destruction of the
tea or there was a broadside the next
morning tea destroyed by indians
um
the british that's that would be a
picture of
done some many years later
by courier knives the lithographers of
the actual event
by the time of the of that event
the british have withdrawn many of their
taxes
but kept the tax on tea
but then they have given a monopoly of
the tea trade to the east india company
the british east india company which is
in london
which drives out the inter
intermediaries the merchants in the
colonies who were importing tea on their
own so they give an exclusive right a
monopoly of tea to the east india
company
they and they put a tax on the t
so the issue that's raised is the same
old issue who has we we have the right
to tax ourselves you don't have the
right to tax us but there's another
issue raised in the issue is of
of uh are you going to give special
favors to british british interests to
as opposed to american interests
and at that point
there's a fear that the
where is where is taxation going what's
going to be taxed next as samuel adams
says in the in the town meeting will
they tax our land next will they tax
windows on our houses so there's a a
general fear of taxes which spreads
through the countryside
the
all over the colonies they resolve they
don't want the tea imported and
elsewhere the t-ships
are turned around and don't land
in boston
the
t-ships land
and
are stationed at the dock they're all
brought to one doc griffin's wharf so
the patriot effort is to
get the royal governor to give a pass to
these t-ships to return to england
and they begin to hold giant meetings it
was all old south meeting house
two meetings in november kind of all day
meetings
and start a process of negotiation to
get the the ships get the ships out of
the port and prevent the tea from
landing
the um the leaders uh station
a small
squadron of soldiers or militia at the
dock to prevent the tea from being
landed
then there are meetings than the all day
on the
15th and 16th of december
1773 1773 right
and uh
as they're conducting negotiations with
the royal governor they sent a
delegation from the from the meeting
these meetings this meeting would be
attended by use and would be attended by
apprentices and by journeyman normally
the town meeting in boston you have to
have a certain amount of property to
attend so maybe there are at most five
or six hundred large meeting will draw
700 people
they cut down the property
qualifications and they say the whole
body of the people may attend so income
what to the gentleman would be called
the rabble or the hoi polloi who would
you let me ask you you mentioned sam
adams who was he then
samuel adams is uh
uh accepted as the leading patriot
figure
uh there is no formal group called the
sons of liberty but the sons of liberty
is the name they assume for themselves
they meet in committees they meet in
caucuses and taverns and samuel adams is
one of the top leaders there would be
about a dozen men
uh who are the leadership where was john
hancock then and who was he john hancock
was the wealthiest man in boston john
hancock owned a fleet of merchant
vessels
he owned a mansion on beacon hill
uh
he employed at tops he might have
employed several thousand people seamen
and people to build ships
uh
he went to harvard he rode to he rode
around town and a coach drawn by
four horses and had livery men he was a
gentleman and he lived in high style
what did sam adams do
samuel adams
was also a harvard graduate he was a
mall star you know there's a beer now
named after
sam adams
uh but he made his he also was the
had an official appointment as the tax
collector and as tax collector in the
city of boston he was very lenient and
let off a lot of people from their taxes
who was john adams john adams is a
lawyer
who lives out in the countryside in a uh
country in a farm also moves into town
for a while and is uh practices law in
town
uh he would be
well in the eyes of the british they
were all radicals but
as the historians separate them out
samuel adams would be in the among the
most radical of the they were called
whig leaders
and john hancock was a merchant whom
samuel adams attempted to win over and
john adams was someone who worked with
with both of them now this guy was 31
then in 1770 in 1773. what was he doing
was he still a shoemaker he's a
shoemaker is he spending any time in the
military
uh no the well
the military for the colonists consists
of the militia which means every every
man over 16 up to 65
was in the militia and would train
several days during the year on militia
training days was he married
he had married in i think 1768
he married a woman who was as laundress
and who was the daughter of a church
sector
and they began to have children
but he was not a well-to-do man in fact
he was put in debtors prison in 1770
because he couldn't pay a debt for the
clothes that he bought and i think he
bought the clothes to impress his wife
while he was courting her how many
children did he have
um
he has three or four children while he's
still in boston
by the end of his life
his wife had given birth to 16 children
not all of whom lived and we can't track
all of them down
but one of them
the 15th lived lived and he named this
15th child 15 which is another story
that was his first name 15.
his first name was 15. yes
did he name did he name a number to
anybody else
after other people was it just just 15
did he have any other never seen no i
think that was his name and we i can't
track all of that down
you mentioned that uh he was only five
two
uh not even five two i think he's five
one yeah he said under five undefunded
five too but the other note was that no
roman catholics were allowed in the
militia
well let's go back a step uh one he was
in a when he was an apprentice
he was not very happy being a shoemaker
he was just i think he was much too
active a person to be to be content
sitting as a shoemaker now we're talking
about george hughes george hughes and he
um
there he is as an older man
he
tries to enlist in the british army in
about 1763
or so
the british
1760s 70 60 61 63 the
that's what was what we since call the
french and indian war a war against the
french
and uh then a british army was
recruiting bostonians to go off to fight
against the french hughes was unhappy
being an apprentice and he tries to
enlist there he has to meet the standard
of the
military which was to be at least five
foot two inches tall and no roman
catholic main list
now why
um
the colonists are almost all protestant
there's a small sprinkling of roman
catholics
the tradition of the british was that
the
the papacy the pope was the enemy of
british freedom
so they all they celebrated in boston as
in great britain guy fawkes day which
was the day in england at which the
uh catholics a small number of catholic
noblemen were
arrested captured
for the so-called gunpowder plot for
trying to blow up the king and
parliament when the king made his annual
visit
ever after they celebrate guy fawkes day
as
the day at which the british were freed
from the menace of the catholic
church
and
the catholic church is considered an
enemy of the british
royal throne and an enemy of great
britain and protestantism is linked up
with patriotism and catholicism is
linked up with the enemy well the
enemies happen to be spain or happen to
be france or catholic and so there's a
mix
of
i think only a small part of it is
religious
much more of it as a kind of traditional
patriotism so
you can't and roman catholic is not
allowed to enlist in the british army
because they're feared as being that
they're not going to be loyal go back to
the destruction of the tea or the tea
party yes griffin's wharf if you've been
to boston
and let's pick quincy market which is
down right near the water how far is
griffin's war from there
nothing's very far from anything else in
boston of those days you could walk from
one end of boston to another in about 15
minutes but isn't that those wars right
along there the uh the wharf is in the
the uh
the main settle part of town is the
north end which now has paul revere's
house
and the middle part of town has the
state house
and faneuil hall which was the place
where the town meeting went
and which is now the quincy market area
to a little bit to the south would be
maybe
four or five blocks would be griffin's
wharf so the tea party begins
in the old south meeting house where 5
000 people are meeting they adjourn
and the
people designated to do the tea party
march from
the old south
meeting house down to griffin's wharf
what actually happens at griffin's war
there are three t-ships
there are about
um 30 people who are designated by the
leadership to board the t t ships
i call them the invited
there's another group
who
sort of invite themselves but are
unknown
they knew that that something was
brewing and they were given word to be
ready use is one of those i call them
the semi-invited
then there's another group even larger
who invite themselves
they are young men apprentices
journeymen who are carried away in the
excitement of the day
the the officially designated parties
dress in the indian disguise
uh with blankets and with war paint
hughes who comes along semi-invited
stops at a blacksmith's shop and puts
some soot from the hearth on his face
and also
carries a blanket
most of those who are at the tea party
were not disguised as indians only a
handful of disguises in these but the
way it comes down in history that we're
all indians and the indians did this
now
they disguised themselves because what
they were doing was very dangerous
and illegal
and
they pretend to be something other than
they are so
it's not us it's indians from someplace
else the mohawks who come in to do this
was anybody killed at the tea party oh
nobody no
did it have any impact
well go back a step they were afraid
they didn't know what would happen i
mean there are it's a very tense moment
um
there are naval british naval vessels
are out in the harbor the british
admiral is on
his
shore watching all of this
the people who are doing this
uh don't know whether troops are going
to be landed to suppress this action
because after all three years before
there were troops in the boston massacre
they have this tradition of troops uh
attacking civilians
the uh there are about a thousand maybe
two thousand people standing on the
wharf watching all of this
the british i think had decided the
royal governor decided earlier he was
not going to call out the troops they
did not want another bloodbath as they
had at the boston massacre
so but but the people doing this don't
know it
they begin the action at six o'clock in
the evening
at 12 o'clock the tea had to be landed
officially so they're working very fast
to throw overboard
the tea
there are 342
chests of tea
very heavy they have to be raised on
winches
broken open with hatchets and the tea
thrown into the sea
so they're working
maybe 150 people in all
in absolute silence
there's moonlight and there's some
lanterns
and all you would hear that night would
be
some muffled orders from one person to
another
and um
the plopping of the tea and the tea
chest into the into the water where's
george hughes george is on board one of
the ships
and uh you get all this from these two i
get this from his two accounts but we
can uh check it out through other
sources because there are other
first-person accounts of what's going on
and then there are official reports back
home from the royal governor and from
other people
so
his version
uh
checks out
uh what's unusual
is
he says he was appointed a bosun a boson
is a person who gives who blows a
whistle to give orders to the other
sailors so he's given some kind of minor
command
at the tea party
uh
sort of a person snatched from the ranks
and given a kind of field appointment
as a quasi officer and he's very proud
of this he talks about this years later
what's the impact of the tea party on
the future declaration of independence
it's very great
the british are furious
it takes several months for the news to
get back to boston
excuse me to london
the uh
they've not only destroyed they've
destroyed 10 000 pounds worth of tea 342
chess with worth 10 10 000 pounds
belonging to the east india company
and they defied the royal governor they
defied the british officials so the
british
parliament brings down
all of its weight on boston they close
the port
until restitution is made for the t
they shut down the royal the town
meeting said the town meeting can't beat
they remodel the central government
they want to pay the salaries of royal
officials
out of the british treasury instead of
being paid by the
colonial government so they can control
them so they as the colonists said they
remodel they the the government and they
take away the rights which the further
rights which the colonists felt they had
so the impact is enormous
uh
and there's a there's the port is closed
uh
boston depended on the sea for supplies
so the cry goes up all through
massachusetts and other colonies to come
to the aid of boston so others send
money they send
small towns will send supplies of meat
and grain foodstuffs to take care of
people and they co in this
uh
their their
sense of rally to the defense of boston
the capital of uh the colonies then in
this country was located where well
there is no single uh uh
capital that's one of the british
problems is each there are 13 colonies
and each state has its own capital so
new york city for
new york philadelphia for pennsylvania
and so forth what's the biggest city
then philadelphia boston would have 15
000 philadelphia i think would have
about 40 000.
when did you start studying the
revolution
when i was in graduate school which
would be in the late 1940s where was
that at columbia university
why did you start studying
well i i thought the revolution was
a kind of uh
founding act in america and would help
explain a lot of what happened
thereafter
where did you live before you went to
colombia i was lived in queens new york
city first went to queens college
and then went to columbia and then went
on to northwestern from my doctorate
studying what
pardon me at northwestern was your phd
at northwestern i took a phd in american
history
you stayed out there
i went i went back east to teach
i taught in
connecticut for a while in new jersey
and then went out
went back to illinois to teach at
northern illinois university and you're
associated now with the newbury yes
since my retirement in 1990 i've been a
senior research fellow at the newbury
library what is the new bearing newberry
is a private independent research
library
which was founded in about 100 years ago
which is a wonderful library in all
history especially early american
history
and in literature philosophy the arts
open to the public anyone who who has a
scholarly need
go to the newbery and people come from
all over the world because the newbery
has a very rich collection of
in the uh renaissance and the history of
the of the first books that are printed
so uh
recently a week ago i wanted to look up
something in a bible that would have
been read in the 18th century so i had
my choice of a
1712 bible or a 1743 bible 1763 bible
and it's very exciting to be able to
open the original books that one that's
what newberry is all about this is a 267
page book uh or about that uh actually
262 with the index it sells for 24.
it's small who do you want to read this
i'd like anybody who's interested in the
american revolution or anybody who's
interested in american history to read
this
i tried to write a book
which would have a broad appeal and
would take which would take up
the kind of history that's not usually
done
namely the history of ordinary people
you say at some point in the book that
um
history was controlled by conservatives
what did you mean by that
well
as soon as the the events in in boston
get going in the revolution there's a
struggle between conflicting groups
the leadership like samuel adams and
john adams
want to keep the so-called mob under
their control
they want people to demonstrate
under their leadership
they're very nervous about people
demonstrating against the british on
their own so for example
um
tarring and feathering is usually
carried out against customs officials or
customs and formers and it's usually
carried out by uh crowds that are
heavily composed of sailors and people
around the docks
uh
they're not approved of by the
leadership
so you literally have a scene
in some of the tarring and feathering
where the leadership will come out and
try to rescue the man who is being
taught and feathered say leave him to
the courts
and
the motto of the leadership in the
decade before the revolution is no
violence or you'll hurt the cause no
mobs no tumults that's their phrase
so they try to control this activity and
they they don't control it at the time
of the boston massacre which is a kind
of chaotic event which nobody wanted to
take place and not done by the
leadership but as soon as the the the
the killing takes place the leadership
rushes out to assume command of the uh
the protest to meet with the royal
governor
the same thing is going on as they as
you report the events
so the leadership
paul revere's engraving of the massacre
is in tune with the way the leadership
wants people to see it that is the
british shooting down a group of hapless
civilians who are completely passive
the truth is that the civilians are
quite aggressive against the soldiers so
there's a struggle
to control
what i call the memory of the revolution
from the beginning
and
um
the leadership is very concerned with
what people will think about boston
boston's reputation as a mobish town and
it deserved it but the leadership was
trying to present the town as being
respectable and having legitimate
protest and so they're able to control
the tea party
now that's the beginning of an effort to
control
the
history of what takes place
then after the revolution that process
continues trying to control
the knowledge of what happened in the
revolution
and
conservatives in the 1790s who would be
called federalists
are very uneasy with this
tradition of the revolution that
stresses
popular activity
it's amazing but in boston the
conservatives for the longest time don't
want to read the declaration of
independence
they don't read it at the fourth of july
celebrations first of all it's very
anti-british and the conservative
federalists are sort of
sympathetic to the british as opposed to
the french
secondly the declaration talks about all
men are being created equal talks about
the right of revolution
and in the 1790s conservatives are very
frightened of the french revolution
and the american revolution kind of
is they want to play down that what we
would call the popular or radical side
of the revolution so in the course of
that they celebrate the fourth of july
but they don't celebrate the tea party
they don't celebrate the stamp back
demonstrations they certainly don't
celebrate the boston massacre
uh
as you move into the 19th century the
descendants of the leadership people
like
harrison gray otis and josiah quincy
after whom the market is named in boston
present a version of the revolution
which i say i use the term they erase
the tea party they erase the boston
massacre they erase the mob side of the
revolution
where is that where is george hughes and
all this at this point i mean go on to
the the feathering of john malcolm that
happens a year after the tea party that
was a few weeks after the tea party uh
hughes
was coming back one day from his teach
from his teacher from his shoe shop
and he encounters john malcolm who was a
customs informer
who had a bad reputation of turning in
ships and turning in ordinary sailors
a crowd hoots
no crowd long hooted it
at uh john malcolm
it's one of these incidents that is
really unbelievable use but is verified
as not only in use accounts it's in the
newspapers you see's john malcolm
a little boy has run into malcolm with a
sled
malcolm raises his cane as if to hit the
little boy hughes rushes in tells him
you can't do that and malcolm brings
down a cane which is a heavy earlier
colonial gentleman's cane on on use his
head
puts a big dent in his head uses taken
off to a doctor hughes then swears those
two adjusters of the piece and swears
out a warrant against malcolm to have
him arrested meanwhile a crowd gathers
and
captures malcolm and proceeds to tarring
tatar and feather him he just stripped
the clothing down to the waist cover him
with tar break open a pillow
cover the man with
feathers
put him in a cart and drag him through
the streets of boston use i mean again
this is the amazing part of the story
who recovered from his wound a doctor
dressed his wound
comes up and sees this event and chases
after after the john malcolm with a
blanket to try to cover him he did not
approve the tarring and feathering
uh which is interesting because the the
the stereotype we have of the mob is of
the mom that's violent and
out to get people and so forth this was
not george around the twelve views
so in 1974 he would be
32 32. and we're getting close to the
lexington and concord which is not more
than 20 miles from downtown boston does
he continue to be a shoemaker during
this period
he's a shoemaker all during this period
i think it's his uh
there's probably not much business going
on in boston
soldiers still there soldiers not only
the soldiers the first batch of soldiers
was taken back then with the
the so-called punitive acts where
they're getting even with boston for the
tea party they send a new army and so
boston is an occupied city it's a
garrison city the royal governor is
replaced by a general
so a general is military governor of the
colony the town meeting can meet only
under a ruse as if it's a continuous
meeting
and then use is acted in the city of
boston against the soldiers do they
still meet in the old
south
uh they would meet in the old south
meeting house
they called their churches meeting
houses and this would be
a sketch of the old south meeting house
100 years later in
1876
when they were afraid it was going to be
torn down was a campaign underway to
save it where is george washington
and the
and others at this point well enter the
enter the american army and enter george
washington after lexington and concord
but first of all when did that happen
lexington and concord is uh the spring
of 1775.
april 17 they
remember it every year in massachusetts
and on that day the famous day when the
shots were first fired where is george
hughes george is in the city
in boston he's not in the militia at
lexington in concord
the uh the soldiers who gather
uh from militia companies from the
surrounding towns
but in 75 he would be active in boston
in
what might be called mob activity
against uh various tories how old is he
in this picture
in this picture he's 93 although they
think he's
near 100 they think he's 99
and he looks very good even for even for
93.
uh so all of this all of this history
that i've been talking about is
recounted when he's in his 90s
everybody thinks his memory is very good
by the way i mean they're just amazed he
remembers
he remembers the names of the four
people killed at the massacre he gets he
calls one christopher addicts not
crispus addicts
he remembers the name of the man who was
his captain of the tea party he calls
him leonard pitts his name was lendl
pitts those are kind of forgivable
we should all be so
remember names as well when when we're
93. i grew up by the way near a high
school called christmas addicts high
school who was christmas christmas
addicts was a sailor who was half black
and half indian
and who was
among the sailors who demonstrated
against the soldiers
so that night of the activity against
the soldiers he was leading a crowd
and he was
wielding a large club menacing
of the the soldiers so he's one of the
first men who shot down
so
uh
in the uh
later on he becomes he's he's a hero
at the time to the uh
to the official dumb he's just he's a
ruffian he's a uh a member of the mob
member of the rabble we've got the stamp
act we then had the massacre we had the
uh the tea party the tar and feathering
of john malcolm and now we're in april
1975 and war is broken out how did it
break out
the the british send
the the patriot militia had been arming
they always had their own arms but they
were storing up gunpowder and storing up
other arms in preparation for likely
encounters with the british army where
did they storm
where did they stay physically where did
they store their
ammunition in um uh
brick storehouses in some of these small
towns the british had gone out earlier
to
capture the uh
the arms in one of the towns
so they went out on the night of the
17th and uh a
large company more than one company b
seven or eight hundred soldiers
to capture arms that were stored and i
think they were after the leadership
that is
samuel adams and john hancock were in
that area
in the lexington area and they wanted a
there was a crackdown
and
firing breaks out on lexington green
and then the army goes on to concord and
there's an armed encounter and the
british army retreats all the way back
to boston and the militia companies that
have that have been pouring in from
other
towns fires at the at the british from
behind trees from behind new england's
famous brick wall mending walls along
the sidewalk and the british army is
devastated by this
indian-like attack george hughes far
away no george george used his back in
uh in boston but about this time that
would be 75 he escapes he gets out of
boston gets out of boston on a roost
he uh he gets a rowboat from someone his
brothers were fishermen
and his brothers may have helped him but
he puts his shoemaking tools in the
bottom of a boat hides them gets a pass
somehow to go out in a rowboat in the
harbor
and uh makes his way to land and then
comes back into cambridge
and he as he tells the story
uh
george washington interviewed him
and wanted information about what was
going on in boston i mean
it's hard to believe and this is one of
those events which i could not i can't
disprove and i can't prove
it could have happened because george
washington was would be interested in
anybody coming out of boston to figure
out
how many troops there are where are they
stationed and so forth
although hughes also had a way of
bringing in famous people into his
narrative and that we can't be we can't
be sure you talk about a lot of
terms and all i just want to make sure
we define some of them that in the book
um
proper bostonians
what's a proper bostonian
well i'm that's the sort of play on on
on words
in the 19th century
uh
a gentleman in boston
would have gone to harvard college she
would be a member of the boston athenian
he would live on beacon street
you would attend one of the new
unitarian churches
you would be a member of the small
number on the massachusetts historical
society
and uh
he would have a sense that uh
there are us and there are them
and that there's only a small circle of
the select i think he would consider
himself a proper bostonian
did you use the
athenaeum up there at all the researches
oh yes it's a very good place to do
research and this is beacon press is
that any relation to the beacon hell
beacon press is on beacon hill at 25
beacon street and beacon press was
founded uh more than a hundred years ago
by the unitarian universe what's now the
unitarian universalist association
and the massachusetts historical society
would only proper boston is belong there
now oh no now it's a much broader
organization but in those days they had
a total of 60 members i think 30
members who were resident of the area
and 30 corresponding members so it would
be
lawyers and merchants and ministers and
they were
not interested in uh
disseminating history they're interested
in collecting history how long was there
actual fighting between the colonists
and the british how many years from 1775
to 1783
and when was the declaration of
independence written in 1776 they're
fighting for a whole year before there's
a declaration of independence did george
hughes ever fight oh yes
he
he leaves he never goes back to boston
he goes to a small town in uh eastern
massachusetts called rentham which was a
family a town where his family was
that's close to boston close to boston
23 miles and
he lives there for some 30 years
he was in the militia out of wrentham or
out of attleboro which is nearby and he
marches off
the militia the militia was not the
regular army the militia was
called upon when there was some danger
of british troops in the area so that
they would serve for one month or maybe
three months
and one of his stints he goes off to
west point for three months stint
then but then he's um
he does what many many thousands of
new england young men would have done
he joined not the navy but a
privateering vessel
to make his service country and make his
fortune the recruiting agent would say
the privateer was a uh
it was a ship that was given a legal
license by the
new state of massachusetts there was
some 2000 of them
to be a pirate to attack british ships
and
if when they captured the ship the booty
then went to the ship and is divided
among
the officers the sailors and the
government
so it's very attractive to men who want
to make their want to make their fortune
now when it was all over what 83
he would have been 39
or they're about somebody he wasn't
what did he do between 39 and age
what do you think his age was when he
died
he's 98 he dies in 1840. he stays a
shoemaker he's in this country town he's
a country shoemaker for the rest of his
life
uh well the evidence
the evidence is seems to be there he
leaves rentham when he was in his 70s
after the war of 1812.
some of his children made their way out
west west then was at sego county new
york
cooperstown
with with the state historical
association now is in the baseball all
of him he lived in richfield springs
and uh
there's a rhyme
uh about old father hughes who made
shoes
so i think he was still a shoemaker
and very much a poor man and very much
dependent on his children
and on the charity of others in the
neighborhood did you ever think about
doing a book about somebody else other
than george hughes were there other
other commoners that would have made
this as interesting a book
well i i wanted to see if i could do
ebenezer macintosh who was the other
shoemaker but there wasn't enough
material about him
since i've uh
uh gotten into this field i now realize
that there are
many many memoirs of people written that
they put down late in their lives uh
of people especially people who were
soldiers and sailors in the war
we have several dozen of them which come
out in the 1820s and 1830s some of them
would would very much could be used for
biographies
uh and i'm now writing
the biography of a woman soldier in the
revolution that's another story what's
her name that's deborah samson ganet
who was a a farm woman
and a
spinner and a weaver and a school
teacher in a small town in massachusetts
and
she disguised herself as a man and
joined the continental army
and got away with it for 17 months
so there was a bog as told to biography
of hers
two some years after the revolution now
who named this the shoemaker and the tea
party a very good editor at the beacon
press named deb jasmine
you like that title i love the title
because i think it uh it raises the uh
the two sides of the book because the
second part of the book
is about the is more about the tea party
and what happens to the memory of the
tea party the first part of the book is
about
hughes and his private memory
the second part of the book is about the
public memory
where i stumbled across this
something i really didn't expect to find
namely that the tea party had been lost
to history for a half a century
it's hard to believe isn't it any
relationship between the lafayette tour
coming over here in 1824
and yes
uh lafayette helps revive this sort of
this hidden history of the revolution so
with the coming of lafayette
uh lafayette comes to boston to dedicate
the bunker hill monument that's the
first the monument the beginning of the
monument they begin to celebrate
uh 1824 1825 50th anniversaries which is
something that we've been doing
ourselves so it's the 50th anniversary
of lexington concord 50th anniversary
the battle of bunker hill then in 26 to
the 50th of the declaration
and these are called jubilees
and in the course of celebrating
the jubilees
you want to bring out
the old soldiers who still survive
and so at the battle of at the
dedication of the bunker hill monument
they find dozens and dozens of old
soldiers
like yous
who become guests of honor for the day
and i think that's the beginning of the
celeb of the sort of the
the uh rediscovery of the shoemaker and
the tea party and our guest has been
alfred young
you can find at the newberry library and
we thank you very much for joining us
thank you very much
alfred young is a professor emeritus of
history at northern illinois university
and the author of numerous books on
american history his book pictured here
the shoemaker and the tea party memory
and the american revolution is available
in both hardcover and paperback by
beacon press
to access the teacher guide that
accompanies this program go to
booktv.org
and click on classroom from there you'll
find a link to classroom materials about
this encore book notes interview with
alfred young
every weekend book tv brings